if we don't have teachers we don't have
anything everybody who's anybody has had
a teacher I would just become a teacher
cause I wanted to motivate people
because it's genuinely rewarding it was
mainly just don't wait to travel but
then I actually quite liked it but it's
really about meeting people talking to
people and help people but I wanted to
make a difference
[Music]
ah I really you know if I weren't a
teacher would definitely be a conductor
my husband thinks I'd be really good at
a children's TV presenting professional
footballer if I wasn't a teacher I
definitely want to be a film director
the best recreation a teacher can have
is for people to tell them how much they
have learnt from them people are quick
to criticize something goes wrong and
not as quick to praise and I think so
this job in particular phrase makes a
big difference
I would like teachers to be recognizing
that as a really important part of the
human development
[Music]
[Music]
everyone everyone says you're so lucky
with the holidays everyone has this
perception that teachers start at 9
finish at 3 and then have six months
worth of holidays a year very little I
can talk about at length of a Welsh
literature I can do handstands there's
too many people I've already got one
injury to date so whenever I say that I
work with teenagers
most people are horrified that I oh my I
don't know how you do that that must be
so hard
we've had some extensive training on how
to deal with it there was a student who
came to my class one day with their
homework in a plastic baggie all like in
wet shreds and they said miss Geller my
two-year-old brother dropped it in his
bath
I said it's okay I'll create it it's
fine